[Musique]
depuis l'émission Apollo on aurait pu
penser en avoir fait le tour mais vous
venez de le voir avec ce documentaire
réalisé par Véronique préau la lune
semble bel et bien redevenu une priorité
pour la conquête spatiale pour des
raisons scientifiques mais aussi et
surtout pour des raisons géopolitiques
financières et commerciales la lune
s'annonce-t-elle comme un nouveau
terrain d'affrontement et bien nous
allons en débattre maintenant avec nos
invités présents sur ce plateau de débat
doc avec vous pour commencer jacquarnou
bienvenue vous êtes historien des
sciences expert éthiques au Centre
national d'études spatiale le CNES bien
entendu et auteur entre autres de ce
livre la guerre de l'espace aura-t-elle
lieu publié aux éditions l'Harmattan ça
tombe bien c'est tout à fait le thème de
cette émission après le film que nous
donc voir ensemble christelle
artoglopine est également avec nous sur
ce plateau bienvenue vous êtes la
directrice générale de starbucks France
Starbucks qui se revendique aujourd'hui
comme le premier créateur aéronautique
spatial et de défense au monde vous
occupez ce poste après avoir
occupé plusieurs postes stratégiques et
cependant 25 ans au sein vous également
du Centre national d'études spatiale le
CNES bien entendu et puis enfin avec
nous Xavier Pasco bienvenue on vous a vu
dans ce film on a vu et entendu pour
témoigner sur l'évolution de cette
fameuse conquête spatiale vous êtes le
directeur de la Fondation pour la
recherche stratégique et spécialiste de
l'espace auteur entre autres de cet
ouvrage Le Nouvel Âge spatial de la
guerre froide au newspace et c'est un
livre publié chez CNRS édition on va
commencer par une question même si c'est
l'état attendue mais elle est bien
entendu évoquée dans ce documentaire
lorsqu'il est question de savoir si on
va vers de nouveaux affrontements
lorsque les questions de conquête
spatiales et notamment de conquête de la
Lune
affrontement et enjeu géopolitique bien
sûr
les États-Unis et la Chine sont-ils en
train de nous refaire le film auquel on
a eu droit au tout début des années 60
et à la fin des années 50 entre eux ce
qui était les deux grandes
superpuissances du 20e siècle autrement
dit l'URSS et les États-Unis et ce qu'on
n'est pas tout simplement en train de
revivre tout à fait la même chose avec
les deux grandes super puissances mais
cette fois du 21e siècle entre les
États-Unis et la Chine c'est ça qu'on
comprend dans ce documentaire
faudrait-il encore que vous nous
expliquer ce que vous entendez par
affrontement parce que vous parlez de
nouveaux affrontements est-ce qu'il y a
eu un affrontement il y a 60 ans en fait
oui il y avait une compétition c'est
très bien rappelé dans dans ce
documentaire et au final donc mais
c'était pas la guerre de la guerre
froide de l'espace est-ce que vous
voulez nous dire il y avait il y avait
tout de même une des enjeux humanistes
on nous rappelle quand même qu'à un
moment donné les Soviétiques les
Américains ont fait cette mission
commune Apollo Soyouz qui était le
dernier la dernière mission Apollo et
l'une des premières vaut pas les
premières mais de Soyouz donc s'il y a
de nouveaux affrontements de ce type là
quelque part nous pourrions presque nous
en réjouir en revanche si c'est des
affrontements plus violents plus
guerriers là ce serait pas des enfin ce
serait des nouveaux ce serait des
affrontements différents effectivement
et cela nous pouvons en avoir peur donc
la question c'est vers quel type
d'affrontement parce que il y a déjà une
compétition comme il y en a eu
auparavant et il y en aura toujours il y
a toujours une conquête parce qu'il y a
la technologie à conquérir pas seulement
des territoires de la technologie de la
connaissance des marchés ça ce qui est
nouveau des marchés à conquérir alors
cela quel type d'affrontement cela va
induire c'est ça pour moi la question
qui est derrière et là il y a quand même
beaucoup d'interrogations
politiques c'est bien entendu votre
votre domaine un nouveau match entre
cette fois les États-Unis et la Chine et
qui passe à nouveau par la lune
c'est ce qu'on découvre dans ce
documentaire ce que tout le monde a bien
compris maintenant depuis quelques
années avec les programmes lancés par
les uns et les autres c'est comme ça
qu'il faut interpréter les choses
néanmoins entre ces deux grandes super
puissances du 21e siècle alors
effectivement dans le contexte actuel il
y a des nouveautés mais l'espace ça
reste une histoire très courte c'est 70
ans d'histoire et la Lune a occupé un
bon bout on va dire de cette histoire et
c'est vrai que l'espace ça reste de
toute façon pour toutes les sociétés
toutes les grandes nations un symbole un
symbole de développement technologique
sociale culturel économique et donc
c'est une case à cocher alors ça c'est
créé dans les dans les conditions de la
guerre froide de manière très
particulière dans un historique très
particulier aujourd'hui on voit une
nouvelle version j'allais dire
effectivement dans une époque où se
confronte de nouvelles grandes
puissances alors une ancienne les
États-Unis une nouvelle qui a émergé
depuis longtemps la Chine et qui coche
d'une certaine manière les cases on le
voit d'ailleurs dans les programmes
qu'ils mettent en œuvre on sent bien que
on passe les différentes étapes qui ont
été les étapes qui ont été franchies par
les États-Unis et en son temps par
l'Union soviétique voilà alors la Russie
décline un peu aujourd'hui donc on est
là-dedans alors après dire on refait la
course de la guerre froide on est plus
model contre modèle tout à fait la Chine
ils font aussi de l'économie ils aiment
beaucoup la performance économique
quelque part on est vraiment dans dans
l'installation de puissance et ça passe
aujourd'hui effectivement contenu du
développement technologiques etc par la
lune à nouveau et là on peut se poser
plein de questions effectivement celle
que Jacques à poser nouvelle des
nouvelles compétitions on va dire alors
qu'il reste un peu géopolitique il y en
a d'autres sans doute technologies
peut-être commercial ça reste encore
quand même un petit peu voilà brumeux
pour l'instant mais on va vers quelque
chose et donc il faut que les grandes
puissances ils soient c'est un peu
d'ailleurs simple un peu ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui à vous dire toutes les cases
mais est-ce que ça coche encore la casse
scientifique il y avait il y avait dans
cette première partie de la conquête
lunaire des interrogations scientifiques
technologiques on a ramené 250 kg
d'échantillons de pierre de des
différentes missions
Apollo et vous l'avez rappelé ça fait 50
ans alors c'est à la fois jeune et sa
demi-siècle hein tout est proportionnel
est-ce qu'il y avait encore des choses à
découvrir sur la lune est-ce que il y a
matière encore à cocher la cage
scientifique ou est-ce qu'on avait fait
le tour comme on avait un peu
l'impression après ces fameuses missions
Apollo de ce que j'ai compris oui
clairement puisque en fait il y a une
réaction de tous les échantillons qui
ont été ramenés de la lune et que c'est
grâce à ça qu'on a découvert que il y a
de l'eau beaucoup plus profondément qui
en a justement sur la face cachée de la
Lune et que c'est pour ça exploré par
les Chinois
et donc effectivement scientifiquement
je pense qu'il y a toujours de recherche
de de l'origine quelque part de notre
planète et la Lune pourrait quand même
rester finalement l'échantillon idéal
pour pour aller creuser ça donc de ce
côté là je pense que scientifiquement et
c'est c'est ça qui est intéressant c'est
que il y a eu alors c'est peut-être un
prétexte mais en tous les cas il y a eu
de nouveau effectivement cette excuse
aussi pour aller sur la Lune sachant
qu'en fait quand même la grosse
motivation aujourd'hui oui c'est
géopolitique et puis c'est surtout le
fait de se doter de cette connaissance
de vivre en milieu contraint pour aller
plus loin je pense que c'est aujourd'hui
c'est surtout ça qui est affiché de la
part de tout le monde et juste pour
revenir par rapport à la Chine moi ce
que je peux noter quand même c'est que
il y a depuis toujours finalement cet
affrontement mine de rien avec avec les
États-Unis ou en tous les cas avec le
reste des acteurs spatiaux puisque la
Chine a toujours été mise au banc
finalement de toutes les coopérations
notamment sur la Station spatiale
internationale et je dirais que la Chine
elle a une revanche à prendre de toute
façon et c'est ça qu'on voit c'est qu'à
chaque fois effectivement et c'est pour
ça que je pense qu'effectivement Jacques
a raison sur le fait qu'on peut quand
même être inquiet on ne sait pas
jusqu'où cette revanche va aller ils ont
quelque chose à prouver mais au-delà et
ça fait longtemps qu'ils ont ça en fait
quelque part en tête donc aujourd'hui
cet aspect géopolitique il est il est
clairement pas anodin et il est presque
moins je dirais moins un peu moins
serein moins gentil que ça n'a pu être
avec nos propos voilà c'est aujourd'hui
je pense que les Chinois ont vraiment
quelque chose à prouver et pour éprouver
quoi alors en allant sur la lune et en
créant leur propre station
spatiale autour de la Lune puisque ça
semble dans leur projet et parce qu'il
n'était pas dans la fameuse station
internationale
vous pourrez prouver quoi en allant sur
la lune
qui risquerait de
ressembler à un début d'affrontement
avec l'autre grande puissance que sont
les États-Unis par exemple
ce que c'est bien Xavier que Christel
c'est déjà bon cocher les cases mais
j'ajouterai ce qui était des cages des
cases même culturelles il y a quand même
enfin évident et c'était présent aussi
dans ce documentaire la lune en arrière
fond culturel c'est présence dans nos
cultures dans toutes nos cultures c'est
ça qui était assez étonnant et pas
étonnant ça se comprend c'est l'objet
céleste le plus proche donc toutes les
cultures de l'humanité depuis le début
de notre histoire sont marqués par la
lune et ça irrigue notre imaginaire ça
explique aussi que il y a un demi-siècle
des Américains aussi bien que les
Soviétiques qui sont allés parce que il
y a une fascination pour la lune et donc
il y a aussi ce qui est présent dans le
documentaire c'est que il y a tout un
pays qui est derrière cette aventure
lunaire parce que tout le monde peut se
reconnaître un jour dans la lune donc
s'embarquer vers la lune c'est aussi ok
le documentaire le dit à plusieurs
reprises c'est embarqué toute une nation
sans embarquer toute une culture et donc
il y a tout un intérêt aussi parce que
par moment
on calme aussi un certain nombre
peut-être de distension sur Terre en
donnant un objectif commun c'est ce qui
avait fait Kennedy il y a 70 ans 61 ans
donc on peut le recommencer et le
documentaire le rappelle des présidents
suivants ont essayé et maintenant c'est
la Chine maintenant et pour compléter ce
qui vient d'être dit sur plan
géopolitique ce sont des grands
programmes qui se font en coopération
sous l'égide d'un chef de fil et ça
c'est pas anodin c'est à dire pour la
Chine est capable de dire j'ai un grand
projet d'installation éventuellement
d'une base sur la lune qui sera ouverte
à la coopération internationale c'est
aussi de la politique et finalement
l'espace est utilisé aussi évidemment on
le sait déjà mais on le voit bien là
dans ce cas particulier à des fins
politiques j'allais dire d'installation
d'une norme de comportement
international pour que la Chine comme
les États-Unis qui le font aussi à
travers leur programme Artemis soit
considéré comme des chefs de fil naturel
régulant d'une certaine manière les
relations internationales jusque dans
l'espace et ça c'est important
politiquement c'est majeur et donc ça
fait partie de la panoplie de la grande
puissance que d'être capable de
s'engager dans les programmes de ce type
en fait et c'est au-delà que vous avez
évoqué tout à l'heure c'est mars et on
va voir un extrait du documentaire
[Musique]
le rêve de Mars vient à la rescousse
pour pousser des projets lunaires jugés
sans intérêt depuis 50 ans
curiosity a dévoilé les contours de la
planète rouge
l'Amérique tout entière a communié
autour de l'événement et renouer avec le
mythe fondateur de la frontière
surtout mars garantit le soutien des
contribuables américains et de
l'ensemble du milieu spatial
alors l'au-delà c'est de faire de la
lune on va dire une planète transit un
transit en tout cas pour pouvoir aller
vers Mars en l'occurrence c'est
évidemment Mars la planète
la plus visée par par les grandes
puissances en compétition là ça change
la donne parce que là on a un nouveau
challenge technologique et là aussi on a
le sentiment que les Américains veulent
prendre
de l'avance sur tout le monde éprouver
qu'ils sont les premiers hommes
peut-être à envoyer sur sur cette
fameuse planète Mars je pense les
Américains et puis encore à nouveau les
Chinois enfin je veux dire là
aujourd'hui on ne sait pas qui va
finalement arriver le premier je pense
que mine de rien les choses ont évolué
depuis le documentaire qui a déjà deux
ans et en deux ans il s'est quand même
passé beaucoup de choses
en 2019 voilà et du coup depuis je pense
que les Chinois ont beaucoup évolué mine
de rien sur ce qui sont capables de
faire sur l'ambition justement qu'ils
affichent beaucoup plus clairement et du
coup effectivement il est possible qu'il
qu'ils arrivent avant mais en tous les
cas y arriver pourquoi faire
effectivement je pense que tous ont la
volonté de s'installer et c'est ça je
pense qu'il fait peur et ça a été
récemment effectivement rappelé par par
Joe Biden alors je ne sais pas quelle
information il a eu sur ce sujet mais
une petite crainte vis-à-vis du fait que
les Chinois en plus s'ils vont
effectivement sur la lune ils y
planterait un drapeau qui
potentiellement
confirmerait que ce territoire en tous
les cas la partie dans laquelle ils
atterriraient leur appartiendrait et
auquel cas à ce moment-là au niveau
géopolitique on est au-delà je dirais de
toute les règlesmentations habituelles
et ça pour le coup ça peut être
déclencheur effectivement de
problématique parce que l'objectif
effectivement c'est de savoir vivre sur
Mars de savoir se nourrir sur Mars de
savoir bouger et de savoir en repartir
pour aller effectivement potentiellement
plus loin et c'est là que ça tire
beaucoup de technologie intéressante et
je vais en profiter pour rappeler que le
principe de la non-propriété de la Lune
a été établie par
[Musique]
quoi qu'il arrive on le voit bien aucune
technologie dans le domaine spatial
n'est définitivement sûre chaque fois
que l'on envoie un engin dans l'espace
et qu'on envoie en plus il est habité on
fait courir des risques donc il y a bien
effectivement encore une conquête de la
Lune parce que ça demande un engagement
humain très important et c'est pas
seulement pour aller
non seulement d'une conquête de la Lune
là mais d'une colonisation
commencez par y retourner lunaire qui
permettrait de mais commençons par
l'étape d'après commençons
dans tous les cas cette épisode lunaire
va nous occuper quand je dis nous
occuper la communauté internationale qui
va y prendre part d'une manière ou d'une
autre pendant au moins deux ou trois
décennies mars c'est quelque chose de
lointain c'est en a coutume de dire dans
le milieu spatial mars c'est dans 30 ans
et quel que soit la date c'est toujours
dans 30 ans et aujourd'hui c'est encore
dans 30 ans les outils qui restent très
compliqué par exemple transporter des
êtres humains vers Mars les fait
traverser des des
c'est vrai et ça risque de le changer
pour les 20 années à venir et les
Américains sont les seuls à jouer ou les
européens font partie intégrante de ce
type de projet alors en tout cas c'est
cet aspect logistique nourrit la
perspective de coopération et explique
cartémie sont un programme intégrateur
donc aujourd'hui une vingtaine ou une 21
pays ont même s'il est des accords pour
savoir qu'on va se comporter sur la lune
etc les Européens sont déjà un petit peu
impliqués comme ils ont développé des
systèmes techniques sur le vaisseau
Orion qui a été testé voilà donc tout ça
participe d'une espèce de coopération
technique sous l'égide des Américains et
souriants testés et ramener sur terre et
ramener sur terre voilà avec un module
de service qui était fourni par
l'industrie européenne et qui a
fonctionné vous inscrivez dans cette
logique là dans cette perspective là
aujourd'hui aussi dans notre esprit tout
à fait en fait c'est vrai que
c'est de la science-fiction
et c'est pour ça que c'est extrêmement
inspirant parce que justement il y a
beaucoup de personnes qui vont aller
au-delà juste du rêve et qui alors c'est
là que ça devient effectivement
complètement différent en plus au-delà
de la logistique c'est que
potentiellement ça peut faire du
business et donc il y a des gens qui
sont en train de du coup de d'imaginer
mais alors c'est tous les jours qui a
des nouvelles startups qui sont en train
de réfléchir sur comment faire du
business avec la lune et d'ores et déjà
effectivement il y a des gens qui
proposent des véhicules orbitaux voilà
effectivement qui vont donc c'est ça qui
est intéressant c'est que c'est en
dehors des états c'est en dehors du CNES
même c'est en dehors de tout ça il y a
une start-up qui a décidé que elle
allait faire un véhicule orbitable
réutilisable qu'on pourra
réalimenter en orbite et elle a levé 20
millions pour ce faire elle a même pas
deux ans d'existence et potentiellement
oui ça elle va trouver son marché d'ici
10 ans pour pour pouvoir alimenter cette
cette station et question de béotien par
rapport à ce qu'on s'est dit tout à
l'heure pourquoi est-ce qu'on a attendu
50 ans
pour pouvoir se dégager des projets de
type Artemis colonisation logistique
pour s'installer sur le sol lunaire et
vouloir aller au-delà pourquoi qu'est-ce
qui s'est passé entre ces 50 ans la
conquête lunaire
on a laissé un petit peu tomber le
projet lunaire pendant un moment il
s'est passé beaucoup de choses en
particulier le fait de commencer à
habiter l'espace autour de la Terre
c'est 50 ans les gens ne sont pas du
tout au tourner les pouces il y a eu
d'abord c'est le programme de la navette
spatiale américaine avec mais ce qui
avait derrière ça et puis son passant
pendant mais son répondant qui a été les
programmes européens comme Ariane tout
ça a servi à quoi d'abord c'est
magnifique lanceur on s'est servi à
mettre des engins et des humains autour
de la Terre et apprendre on rejoint ce
que disait Xavier tout à l'heure avant
d'aller affronter les espaces
interplanétaires il faut déjà affronter
l'espace autour de la Terre qui
nécessite un espace très hostile donc et
regardez la tête des astronautes il y a
50 ans et la tête des astronautes
aujourd'hui s'il reviennent aujourd'hui
avec un temps toujours aussi blanc parce
que n'en voit pas le soleil mais quand
même en meilleure santé c'est parce que
durant ces 50 ans nous avons appris à
vivre de plus en plus longtemps dans
l'espace ne serait-ce que ça ça occupe
je te disais Christelle ça occupe
jusqu'à présent ça que fait surtout les
États et les nations et les organismes
de recherche et aujourd'hui en plus ça
occupe tout ce monde qu'on appelle une
space tous ces entreprises qui veulent
aussi faire quelque chose et peut-être
demain faire du business ça occupe le
secteur privé on y arrive bien entendu
vous l'avez prononcé le mot business
c'est un nouvel enjeu de la conquête
spatiale nouvelle extrait du
documentaire
le business des milliardaires de
l'espace c'est le lancement des
satellites
en inventant une nouvelle génération de
fusées capable de revenir se poser sur
terre et d'être réutilisé ils ont
bouleversé le marché des lanceurs fait
chuter les prix et mise en danger les
leaders d'autres fois les agences
spatiales
[Musique]
alors voilà un exemple type des enjeux
commerciaux qui sont maintenant à la
base de cette nouvelle conquête spatiale
emploi comme ça c'est new space c'est le
terme utilisé avec trois acteurs privés
majeurs qui ont fait leur entrée sur ce
marché on va tout de même les citer même
s'ils ont été cités dans le documentaire
SpaceX assez Elio de musk blue Origins
c'est Jeff Bezos donc le patron d'Amazon
et Virgin galactique série chart Bronson
voilà trois personnes qui sont tous sauf
des philanthropes et on se dit que si
des acteurs privés commencent à
s'intéresser à la conquête spatiale
c'est que bien entendu il y a de
l'argent à se faire
c'est la réalité oui
business spatial alors déjà ce qu'il
faut bien comprendre quand même c'est
que ces trois c'est trois milliardaires
aujourd'hui bon d'abord ils ont fait
fortune par ailleurs mais ça fait quand
même 20 ans qui sont motivés par ce
sujet là ça fait 20 ans voilà comme quoi
le spatial enfin ça se fait pas non plus
aussi vite qu'on le voudrait même avec
beaucoup d'argent mais du coup ils ont
réussi on a trois caractères
complètement différents mais en tous les
cas une chose est sûre c'est que
techniquement Elon Musk pour moi c'est
la chose la plus intéressante parce
qu'il a travaillé autrement avec
d'autres principes si vous voulez il a
travaillé avec le fail fast pour aller
plus vite et effectivement ça c'était
nouveau par rapport je dirais au
programme historique justement des
agences spatiales qu'on connaît et qui
sont toujours les mêmes aux États-Unis
la NASA s'appuie sur des acteurs
historiques comme le Kim Martin comme
Boeing qui travaille un peu comme chez
nous effectivement mais là lui il a
travaillé autrement voilà en disant je
vais vers l'échec qui était
extraordinaire et ce qui a effectivement
changé je pense la donne mine de rien
par rapport à la réussite qu'il a qu'il
a pu prendre
des risques en matière de conquête
spatiale et lui semble-t-il les appuis
et du coup avec des échecs voilà assumer
enfin bon et ça ça a permis
effectivement aujourd'hui de changer la
donne parce que ça permet de convaincre
les investisseurs d'aujourd'hui que oui
on peut gagner de l'argent avec le
spatial ce qui jusqu'à présent n'était
pas forcément imaginable enfin quand on
voit nous au niveau des lanceurs voilà
un lanceur n'est pas rentable bien
évidemment il faut tout la chaîne autour
pour que ce soit rentable et donc ça
avait naturellement c'est les États qui
peuvent financer parce qu'il n'y a pas
de retour sur investissement or
maintenant effectivement on tire la
pelote de toutes ces nouvelles de toutes
ces nouvelles technologies de ces
nouvelles idées qui ça peut être juste
sur un véhicule mais ça peut être sur
l'ensemble effectivement de la chaîne de
valeur jusqu'à un habitat complet sur la
lune ou potentiellement un investisseur
qui va subventionner enfin qui va
investir dans une start-up pourra avoir
un retour sur investissement et ces
trois acteurs majeurs mais il y a
derrière une carrière de start-up qui
commence effectivement comme vous l'avez
dit à s'agréger et à travailler pour
cette conquête spatiale des nouvelles de
gagner de l'argent aussi avec elle hein
donc les investissements
privés dans le dans la conquête spatiale
est-ce que ça va déséquilibrer
la donne est-ce que ça va créer cette
fois de nous vous affrontements mais sur
un terrain commercial et purement
business moi j'ai pour moi répondre au
début de votre question c'est que
évidemment ça bousculé c'était précisé
dans ce documentaire les acteurs dit
historiques qui n'avaient rien vu venir
donc avec
ou refusé de voir venir des nouveaux
acteurs sachant que ces nouveaux acteurs
dont nous parlons aujourd'hui n'étaient
pas les premiers à avoir tenté cette
aventure mais que vous posez la question
du temps s'il a fallu ce temps là c'est
que il y a des moments opportuns il y a
une opportun et il y a une ouverture qui
s'est faite grâce à l'administration
américaine il y a une bonne dizaine
d'années ou même plus une quinzaine
d'années et dans laquelle dans cette
brèche on peut rentrer des gens comme
Elon Musk avec une fougue avec une voilà
une une
absence de enfin une prise de risque
réel qui fait que lui a réussi mais il y
a toujours des perdants faut jamais
oublier que pour un qui gagne il y en a
qu'un seul qui tient dans une
compétition il y a toujours des perdants
et il a peut-être il a failli perdre
plusieurs reprises et qui en a encore il
y aura encore des perdants n'oublions
pas que les startups c'est pas l'espace
qui les a créé enfin le concept ça a
déjà été mis en œuvre aux parents avec
d'autres technologies avec des réussites
plus ou moins relatives est-ce qu'on
peut dire et parce qu'il y avait
peut-être un peu une ambiguïté dans le
documentaire qu'on vient de voir que ce
sont des encore des sous-traitants des
intérêts publics ces acteurs privés ou
est-ce qu'on est déjà passé à autre
chose
en terme technique et juridique il y a
des différences maintenant alors on a
des nouvelles entreprises je dirais que
moi je caractériserai les choses à la
manière suivante on avait auparavant des
acteurs institutionnels comme les
agences spatiales qui étaient les seuls
à voir la fois des capacités des
objectifs et les industriels étaient
finalement ceux qui exécutaient leur
plan voilà on construisait la NASA
faisait le plan de la fusée Boeing ou
lokid que vous avez cité réalisé la
fusée et la NASA vous plairait la fusée
et Boeing était très content toucher
l'argent du voilà et bien on a tout d'un
coup quelqu'un comme Elon Musk qui
arrive et qui dit ben voilà moi je veux
aller sur Mars entre autres et je vais
faire des fusées pour ça et donc
évidemment ça ça perturbe un petit peu
les choses ça c'est le début des années
2000 et puis la NASA elle-même c'est
bien qu'elle doit moderniser ses
relations avec l'industrie parce qu'en
même moment la des relations difficiles
avec cette industrie traditionnelle qui
coûte ce qui est lourde etc et donc elle
saisit l'occasion sous l'impulsion
politique et là il faut vraiment pas
sous-estimer le rôle de gouvernement
américain qui est orchestré tout en fait
on a réorganisé les relations entre le
secteur public et secteur privé et
finalement stimule évidemment ce
gouvernement américain cela fait partie
de la culture américaine le secteur
privé et par la commande publique il
faut vraiment ne jamais oublier que
l'essentiel de l'argent qui sort qui
circule dans le domaine spatial c'est de
l'argent d'origine public et là on a un
atteint dans ce nouvel épisode de la de
l'activité spatiale des des montants
considérables pour ce programme lunaire
on dépense à milliard si vous voulez et
Elon Musk a très bien compris ça et lui
il se satisfait très bien d'avoir ses
propres plans mais éventuellement
évidemment de se mettre dans le siège de
la NASA pour les aider sur Artemis c'est
ce que va faire Jeff Bezos aussi donc on
est dans une espèce de modèle hybride on
n'est pas de compétences d'une
privatisation de l'espace moi je je me
méfie toujours un peu de mais
effectivement on a de nouveaux acteurs
privés qui entretiennent une relation
différente avec le l'acteur public et je
vais être obligé de citer quelques
chiffres pour
pour c'est le matérialiser un petit peu
l'ampleur de de ce que de venir ce que
pourrait devenir ce marché spatial le
marché en tout cas les investissements
liés spatial étaient estimés à 3,35
milliards de dollars entre 2010 et 2014
entre 2015 et 2019 ils sont passés à
16,84 milliards d'euros et d'après la
banque Morgan Stanley alors évidemment
hein les revenus de l'industrie spatiale
pourraient être multiplié par 3 d'ici
2040 et dépasser ainsi les 1000
milliards de dollars donc on sent bien
qu'il y a un lien il y a un potentiel et
concernant la lune et ça c'est
intéressant parce que là aussi il y a
visiblement des enjeux
commerciaux voire spéculatifs la lune
regorge notamment de ressources
naturelles que l'orgne les États
notamment l'hélium 3 présent en grande
quantité sur le sol lunaire grâce à la
fusion nucléaire ce dernier pourrait
produire suffisamment d'énergie pour
notre planète pendant 1000 ans et ce en
prenant uniquement en compte les
quantités de ce fameux hélium 3 dans les
trois mètres de en profondeur du sol
lunaire on comprend que ça puisse
encourager les investissements oui alors
bon moi je suis pas complètement
convaincue par les trois mais pourquoi
pas je pense que c'est plutôt tout ce
qui va autour en fait ça reste vous
savez ceux qui ont fait fortune dans le
Far West c'est quand même ceux qui
vendaient les pelles ce qui vous a mangé
voilà donc ça c'est peut-être qui
potentiellement peut attiré avec les
montants que vous avez cité c'est
vraiment ça qui aujourd'hui fait rêver
les investisseurs voyez ce que jusqu'à
présent les investisseurs du souffre
dans le spatial d'abord ça n'existait
pas donc depuis 5-6 ans en France ça
existe de manière vraiment assez assez
conséquente on va dire pas suffisamment
en France pour qu'on soit capable quand
même d'avoir une licorne française dans
le domaine donc ça je tiens quand même à
le répéter mais par contre effectivement
en ce moment il y a une vraie prise de
conscience sur le fait que
potentiellement oui il y a de l'argent à
se faire je dirais sur sur cette
exploitation de la lune que soit les
lions 3 ou les pelles qu'on va vendre
enfin globalement il y a un business
effectivement mais ce qui ce qu'il faut
effectivement rappeler quand même c'est
que c'est ce business là ne serait rien
sans les acteurs historiques qui mine de
rien quand même ont un savoir un
savoir-faire et puis potentiellement ont
besoin de ces de ces nouvelles startups
de ces nouvelles idées ont besoin aussi
de se faire un peu challenger enfin ce
que je veux dire par là c'est que tout
ça c'est un bel écosystème que justement
nous on se fait fort effectivement
d'animer parce que on est persuadé que
c'est grâce à ça que on pourra
finalement passer passer l'étape quoi
qui va sur cette exploitation on va
rester sur ce terrain commercial nous
reste trois minutes avant la fin de
cette émission il est dit dans ce
documentaire qu'entre 400 et 36000 km de
la Terre il existe plus de 2000
satellites aujourd'hui
représentant 60 pays et des compagnies
privées cet espace dans l'espace
concentre
95%
du business de l'espace
et le nombre de satellites devrait
tripler c'est là que se situe
aujourd'hui les principaux enjeux
commerciaux et pas encore sur la Lune
bien sûr donc on connaît déjà cette
l'exploitation et la gestion et la
gouvernance cet espace là et ça qui est
intéressant on n'est pas du tout dans un
endroit hors-la-loi il y a bientôt 70
ans de 65 ans de
gouvernance international
d'habitude de travailler ensemble de
gérer ensemble parce qu'on n'envoie pas
des satellites n'importe comment
n'importe où il y a des tas d'enjeux
on a pas le droit aux armes nucléaires
dans l'espace
internationaux ou la gestion des débris
dont on parle très souvent et donc tout
ça sont des endroits des thèmes me
semble-t-il très intéressant parce que
nous avons déjà appris à gouverner
ensemble cet espace là proche de la
Terre et donc nous ne partons pas de
zéro et quel que soit l'évolution et qui
est comme Xavier exponentiel en termes
de nombre de satellites vous avez cité
des chiffres qui ont déjà trois ans
aujourd'hui il faut multiplier ce
chiffre par deux déjà par trois donc
voilà c'est bien plus compliqué à gérer
mais nous ne partons pas de rien et tout
l'enjeu aujourd'hui c'est de faire en
sorte que les acteurs historiques et les
nouveaux acteurs et bien se rencontrent
se voit se débattre ensemble pour
pouvoir aussi partager confronter leurs
différents intérêts il y a les intérêts
historiques et vous intéresse il y a des
intérêts politiques des intérêts
économiques et ça c'est l'enjeu
aujourd'hui et puis on va finir
là-dessus parce qu'il y a tout de même
des intérêts militaires ils ont pas été
évoqué le nombre documentaire qu'on
vient de voir la France est dotée il y a
pas si longtemps d'un commandement et
d'une quatrième armée on peut dire les
choses comme ça une armée de l'espace
les États-Unis créent un sixième corps
d'armée consacré également à l'espace là
aussi terrain d'affrontement la conquête
spatiale l'affrontement militaire cette
fois alors quels sont les risques oui
terrain d'affrontement d'abord ça
reflète une chose c'est qu'on devient de
plus en plus dépendantes d'espace donc
évidemment une composante importante de
la société c'est sa défense donc la
défense s'intéresse à l'espace et
d'autant plus que pour le cas de la
France par exemple vous avez cité la
création du commandement de l'espace on
s'est aperçu dans les dernières années
on dépendait de plus en plus de l'espace
pour mener les opérations que ce soit
dans la bande sahélienne que ce soit un
peu partout on le voit aujourd'hui que
la Russie etc et donc il faut il faut on
devient dépendant système sterling voilà
notamment
et on devient dépendant d'un
environnement qu'on maîtrise d'une
certaine manière de moins en moins bien
parce que comme le disait Jacques de
plus en plus d'objets tout ça évolue
très vite on a de plus en plus de mal à
savoir ce qui s'y passe vraiment parce
qu'il y a des petits objets donc quand
vous devenez dépendant de quelque chose
que vous contrôlez moins bien vous vous
réorganiser pour essayer de pallier le
problème c'est vraiment ce qui se passe
ça se passe pour tous les grands pays y
compris les États-Unis qui ont plus de
capacité à savoir ce qui se passe mais
l'espace ça reste très grand très
compliqué et c'est en accélération c'est
à dire qu'on va avoir effectivement de
plus en plus d'objets en orbite qui vont
bouger on va faire ces opérations
logistiques ce qui implique des
manœuvres ce qui implique des
rapprochements donc tout ça incite les
militaires à penser protection et à
penser le cas échéant opération
militaire alors ça c'est tout à fait
nouveau et là évidemment on est
aujourd'hui je dirais au carrefour de la
voilà
d'une évolution qui peut-être vraiment
problématique mais qui n'est pas encore
totalement écrite je pense qu'on doit
aller vers plus de transparence on est
tous interdépendants dans l'espace ça on
l'a tous appris et ça quand même ça
oblige un peu les gouvernements à
réfléchir et à discuter en tout cas
espérons-le ça sera le mot de la fin
vraiment un grand merci à tous les trois
ça va participer à ce débat doc
aujourd'hui pour parler bien sûr de la
conquête spatiale de cette lune comme
huitième continent aujourd'hui c'était
le titre de notre documentaire vos
réactions ce sera sur
#dadoc sur Twitter bien entendu merci à
sel massali qui comme à l'accoutumée m'a
aidé à préparer cette émission puis moi
je vous donne tout simplement
rendez-vous pour un prochain débat doc
et ça sera bien sûr avec son
documentaire et son débat à bientôt
[Musique]